but i already knew she was you know
different from the moment
we were doing youtube videos and stuff
together that like
hey one day she is going to be really
famous probably forget about me
and that you know that's insecure me
talking back in the day yeah
you know we're obviously still really
close this day but that
when she was coming up to be honest um
a little bit of like the comparison game
and and you kind of wanting to be at
that level that affected me
mentally and that that was kind of part
of why i took a hiatus
in 2014. i don't really say that often i
don't even know if i've
i've said that out loud really but when
you're com
comparing yourself especially to a
friend who's like
blowing up you know that that can get to
you if you're if you're unable to get
out of that that hole you know everyone
offers i really believe this and we're
talking about
getting out of the box musically but
even if you don't you still have your
own uh voice and and something to offer
somebody yeah you know what i mean um
and back then i wasn't
i wasn't hearing i didn't know if i was
and i didn't know if people
would listen to me if i if i
didn't collaborate with someone like
tori kelly or be associated with
you know so that was a big kind of
struggle
in in my career and obviously i'm in
such a better place now and
i and we are both genuinely happy for
her and it does kind of sometimes take
some words of affirmation as well from
that person maybe you know we had a
seven year anniversary of red roses a
couple years ago a show
and she came out and surprised everyone
she sang nobody loved which was her
single on the video you know and uh
you know after she comes out and
surprises and then we sing the duet
that's on red roses
before that she was like aj i wouldn't i
wouldn't be here if it weren't for you
wow you know and and you hearing that
from someone you obviously look up to
but also someone that you've
helped along the way and she in turn has
helped me in so many ways to hear that
is uh it means a lot you know that's
kind of nuts and i think that's hard for
some people to even
vocalize that out because you don't want
to feel these certain things about your
personal friends
but at the same time art is so [ __ ]
personal it's hard not to sometimes
you know i think oh totally it's it's a
hard pill to swallow especially when you
have dreams and aspirations of your own
and it's not to say that
you look at your friend and you hate
them for it but a little piece of you is
kind of like
don't i deserve that as well sure you
know yeah and it's hard to say that out
loud
because it makes you feel like a
terrible friend and you feel like a
terrible person
and so you know i've definitely like i'm
i'm definitely in that realm too but
like i said i do it in a negative way
where somebody i don't know
and i see them they book something and
i'm like you're trash
you know what it is i'll do that too and
i'll do it [ __ ] better than you yeah
you know it's it's it's one of those
things man and i think it's very nice
that you could say that out loud because
a lot of us sometimes go under the skies
of saying
well i'm the i'm the friend that if my
friend does well i'm always happy
true 100 we're always happy but there's
still a part that we want for ourselves
yeah dude
not everyone's going to admit that for
sure yeah it is
it's a pride thing you know you want to
keep your pride and be like
yeah dude if my friend does this i'm
going to be
yeah and that's not the case and you
don't have to
lie to yourself necessarily um because
once you
do kind of confront it and know that it
doesn't come from a place of like
hatred or whatever and and maybe you are
a little jealous then it
once you admit that to yourself that
starts kind of like the quote-unquote uh
healing process of that and you becoming
true in your intention of of being happy
for somebody yeah and it has nothing to
do with them
it's just it's just our personal want as
an artist right and sometimes
it's when you look back and you
everybody goes to this stuff especially
when people hit their
i don't know midlife crisis when they're
40 they look back and they see that i
could have done more and i wanted more i
didn't
get it yeah it's a very hard pill to
[ __ ] swallow yeah
you know especially you know i mean tory
kelly is a unique case too where she
has accomplished what every musician
wants to accomplish
you know it's true and it's above and
[ __ ] beyond you know
and there's some places i think like for
you and manifest isn't a really good
thing right where
it caused you to reflect versus putting
that upon her it's not her
it's more like oh i have to reflect on
myself which is oh completely it would
have been so unfair
if you know if she heard
that i was going through that and i was
like blaming
her or whatever or whatever it was you
know what i mean because
yeah you're right it's it's not them
it's kind of you're
it's it's all within within you yeah and
and that does come with just like life
experience
and learning more and and you know
hopefully getting good advice from your
friends that are not like
they're not just yes men and they're
like you should definitely be as famous
as
so-and-so and x you know what i mean and
blah blah blah and all these things
you know has to come from a healthy
place yeah because i had a friend of
mine who did a stand-up at the same time
that i did right and i decided to go
into the youtube route
and i tried to help him out too but his
videos [ __ ] sucked it is what it is
and when i left to la uh
yeah so yeah it's [ __ ] it was
sucked so when i went left to la and i
told the story before
he came out of nowhere with this long
just arbitrary
letter out of left field on facebook
messenger about how
he goes yo i just want to say i'm super
proud of you blah blah whatever what not
but i want to let you know that i was
really salty when you didn't take me to
la with you
and i was like what am i your [ __ ]
mom [ __ ] wow
you know what i mean like what the [ __ ]
if you wanted to come to la you should
have came
yeah you should sacrifice the same [ __ ]
i sacrificed i had
i had 200 bucks i think in my bank
account that's it i sold
everything that i had and i did it and
it made a huge risk yeah if you wanted
to come along you could have
but you kind of ended that with like i
just want to let you know that i'm not i
don't think you're a better comic than
me but i think we're just different
right and i just and i wrote back the
most
i just wrote back this you know i kind
of wrote back this and i'm just
paraphrasing it right now i know exactly
what i said but i said something along
the lines of if you were just as good as
me you would be where i am right now but
you're not that's why you are where you
are and that's why i'm at where i'm at
so when you're when you're here then
then you can come back there
bro right why you said so it's like how
do you and first of all i never thought
an ill thought about him and he comes
outside
i'm like what the [ __ ] i thought we were
friends yeah especially out of nowhere
you're like what the hell it was like
two three years he didn't talk to me at
all
you know and i thought because he was
doing a stand-up i thought he was doing
well in stand-up
and it was just a different route i
stopped doing stand-up i was still doing
it here and there sure but
i decided to do youtube mainly and then
stand up was supplementary after a while
after i realized that stand-up wasn't
something i really really wanted
but it was kind of weird hearing that
from him and it pissed me off a little
bit
i was like bro i'm over here saying good
[ __ ] about you you know
but i think you did it in a good way
where it was like i feel this way
and it's something that i'm dealing with
and you didn't put that pressure on her
totally you know and you still loved her
for it yeah you know which is awesome
no totally man i mean i think that's
yeah and and hopefully people when
they're coming up in music they make
actual genuine
relationships and friendships you know
where like where the music actually
that's secondary you know what i mean
it's for me too
i've always put music first and i'm
always like i
i believe in music that's like on my
twitter profile or whatever you know i
almost put music before
my family sometimes before like my faith
in god and things like that you know
but at the end of the day you know we're
all humans and and we have
it's all relationship